Buckingham Palace is now in crisis after
it was blindsided by Prince Harry and
wife Megan's announcement that they were
stepping back from their royal duties
there are reports of Prince Charles was
only given a 10-minute notice of the
world couples plans as Prince Harry
negotiates his future megan is back in
Canada MTS tyub is in London with the
latest MTS good morning good morning
Michelle well some of britain's tabloid
press are continuing to rage at harry
and megan after that major announcement
but it would seem public opinion is
increasingly on the royal couple's side
with the recent poll suggesting half of
Brits support their decision
highlighting a disconnect with the press
some say is propelled by racism for the
first time since that royal bombshell
were seeing the Queen driving outside
her Sandringham Estate looking in
control while behind the scenes things
are anything but the 93 year old monarch
has reportedly been holding crisis talks
with grandson Harry William and son
Prince Charles while Britain's tabloid
press are still fuming at Harry and
Megan the nation they say is shocked but
for fo Hirsch who's written extensively
about Megan it's not shocking at all
many people of color in Britain are
saying we know exactly why she's leaving
we have seen the racism towards her play
out in real time and one of the
incredible ironies of this situation is
the very commentators in the media that
have busied themselves hurling racist
abuse that megan Markel for month after
month are now the ones professing to be
the most shocked that she's reacted
there are so many examples of the racism
that's been directed towards megan
Markel in some cases there's nothing
subtle about it also not being seen as
subtle this latest Instagram post from
the couple's official account Harry and
Megan visited this London community
kitchen they've long been supportive of
just a few days ago giving us an
affectionate glimpse perhaps of the
progressive new role as Royals they say
they want to create for themselves the
Megan's already back in Canada to be
with little Archie and it seems to be as
far away from this crisis as possible
Prince
we'll stay here for the next two weeks
before joining them working out with his
family would he his wife and his son's
future will look like as Royals who
stepped back Jeff yes thank you very
much see that look the Queen gave I mean
for what she was driving the Range Rover
there that was a fierce look yeah you
know there might be some prophetic there
is you remember that that that theater
play Charles King Charles the third it
was on Broadway a couple of years back
it had a very similar point that he was
going to marry someone that would take
him out and so a lot of people are
talking about that
you